bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver en
direct sur figaro là et vous le savez
chaque fois qu'une actualité vous
intéresse nous répondons à vos
commentaires et vos questions en direct
grâce à nos experts aujourd'hui c'est la
sphère des sous-marins que nous avons
choisi de vous de traiter avec vous la
crise entre la france et les états unis
après l'annulation par l'australie de
l'achat de sous marins français au
profit d'un partenariat stratégique avec
washington et londres vous fait beaucoup
réagir et vous interroge isabelle
lasserre correspondante diplomatique au
figaro et sébastien falletti
correspondant du figaro en asie sont
avec nous en direct ce matin pour vous
livrer leurs analyses on les remercie
tous les deux des trains directs avec no
mercy zabel merci sébastien merci
sébastien alors la crise des sous-marins
fait la une de l'actualité en france
depuis plusieurs jours la réaction de la
france justement qui a rappelé ses
ambassadeurs aux états unis en australie
et qui a eu des mots très durs pour les
deux pays démontrent que du point de vue
de la france la crise est grave mais
isabelle lasserre qu'en est il du point
de vue des américains comment washington
père soit elle la fureur de la france
quand on entend joe biden affirmé hier
soir à l'onu que les états unis n'ont
pas d'alliés plus proche ou fiable que
l'australie on a peu de doute sur le
message oui cerlogne justement vous
l'avais dit dans votre dans votre
question les et les américains
considèrent parle de la furie française
donc là une espèce d'incompréhension
sur la manière dont
réagit le réagissent les autorités
françaises qui il est vrai ou fait
preuve d'une colère froide parce que le
rappelle l'ambassadeur pour
consultations ça arrive assez rarement
entre alliés alors quand joe biden en
remet une couche hier à la tribune de
l'onu
effectivement en disant que l'australie
est le meilleur ami le meilleur allié
des états unis c'est encore une gifle à
la france
puisqu'elle était considéré jusque là
depuis le brésil comme le meilleur allié
des états unis en tout cas en europe et
surtout pour des questions
militaires et de défense sébastien
falletti vous êtes en direct avec nous
depuis l'asie depuis la corée et du côté
de la chine alors comment réagit pékin à
ce nouveau pacte de sécurité qui vise à
endiguer à contrer la puissance chinoise
est ce que la chine se sent cerner
évidemment la chine a vertement dénoncé
celle ce pacte elle a parlé de d'une
alliance qui savent qu'ils rappellent ce
qu'elle appelle le temps de la guerre
froide elle a appelé les etats-unis à
abandonner cette mentalité de la guerre
froide
ces propos trahissent une véritable
inquiétude chez les stratèges de pékin
parce que comme vous le dites il ya le
sentiment d'un encerclement croissant
les chinois voient dans cette se pacsent
pack trilatérale qui inclut le royaume
uni une forme de nouvelles alliances
militaires une sorte de autant
asiatiques avaient clairement la volonté
de contenir la chine même si les états
unis ne le disent pas ouvertement et
pékin le comprend très bien donc il ya
une véritable inquiétude cette décision
locus fait monter les enchères stratégie
en asie puisque elle signale le retour
pleinement des états unis sur la scène
asiatique sur le long terme avec une
montée en gamme puisqu'on passe comme
vous l'avez dit de deux sous-marins
conventionnels ce que les français
préparaient à des sous marins à
propulsion nucléaire on pourra revenir
plus tard sur ce que cela signifie mais
c'est clairement
symboliquement pour toute la région et
bien sûr pro pkr le signe que les états
unis sont là pour longtemps et sont
prêts à
monter en gamme leur présence pour
contenir les ambitions chinoises
comprenez-vous qui nous suivez en direct
sur figaro là il va sur youtube l'inde
au pacifique est devenu le nouveau
centre de gravité du monde on peut dire
ça comme ça puis c'est aussi le mot
qu'on entend beaucoup ces derniers temps
qui dans la bouche de beaucoup qu'en est
il en train de se jouer pour les grandes
puissances dans cette fameuse zone indo
pacifique dont tout le monde parle
depuis l'annnonce de ce pacte hocus
signé entre l'australie les états unis
et le royaume uni eh bien on vous répond
ce matin n'hésitez pas à nous poser vos
questions nous livrer vos commentaires
sur ce sujet je vous rappelle qu
isabelle lasserre
correspondant diplomatique le figaro et
sébastien falletti correspondant du
figaro en asie sont là avec nous on
dirait que ce matin pour répondre à
toutes vos questions sébastien falletti
je reste avec vous ou encore
par rapport à la chine quelle
opportunité la chine pourrait-elle tirer
justement des déboires de la france
quelles stratégies pour est elle même
envisagé vis-à-vis du vieux continent
alors effectivement
pour la pour la chine
'l'annonce blocus est une mauvaise
nouvelle
clairement à comme j'ai dit elle se sent
en cercle et maintenant la chine est
restée assez prudentes pour le moment
ces derniers jours elle elle met en
valeur notamment un argument qui est
suivi du risque de prolifération en
disant que les états unis acceptent de
partager une franchissent une ligne
rouge en partageant delà du savoir faire
nucléaire donc elle essaye de faire
monter
la pression sur le plan interne à cette
question là évidemment la chine depuis
longtemps appelle les européens à l
union européenne à sortir de l'orbité
américaine et avoir un
partenariat avec elle qu'ils soient soi
disant indépendants donc elle me met en
avant des intérêts commerciaux et on a
vu que les européens tous partir
allemand l'allemagne mais aussi la
france sont sensibles à ces appels du
pied on sait que en décembre dernier
l'union européenne a signé un très
controversé accord d'investissement avec
la chine juste avant que
l'administration by john arrive aux
affaires et on ne peut pas s'empêcher de
penser qu'à washington beaucoup
aujourd'hui pense qu'ici il ya une
petite revanche qui se prend les
européens qui avaient fait qu'ils
avaient pris de vitesse des mannequins
et dessus donc les européens nés en
particulier berlin et paris veulent
conserver des rapports commerciaux
étroits avec la chine et donc voit d'un
mauvais oeil la montée en puissance
américaine contre la chine donc il ya
une différence d'appréciation de la
monnaie chinoise qui est clair et la
chine espère tirer profit de ses
divisions transatlantique donc c'est
effectivement le observe actuellement ce
qui est en train de se passer à
bruxelles les tensions franco américaine
évidemment sont en train d'être observés
par pékin pour voir s'il ya des moyens
de les exploiter dans les prochaines
semaines et prochains mois un petit mot
isabelle lasserre sur ce que dit
sébastien falletti justement sur la va
dire la perception ou
l'ambition de la france versus les
américains sur la stratégie à adopter
vis-à-vis de la chine les etats unis
sont plus dans dans le registre de la
confrontation la france est plus dans la
négociation va dire ou dans une
temporisation une des relations un peu
plus - moins frontal on va dire qu'est
ce qu'on peut dire aujourd'hui
effectivement du rapport de la chine
avec la france par rapport à la position
de la france on peut dire que
l'ajustement la position française en
fête est une espèce de troisième voie
c'est aussi le cas de l'europe mais
c'est la france qui est vraiment un peu
le fer de lance de cette voie médiane
qui consiste à ne pas être naïf
vis-à-vis de la chine et en même temps à
ne pas se confronter directement
vis-à-vis d'elle depuis le début by
donne et à ventre on essaye d'en mener
l'europe et la france
dans cette confrontation qui n'a pas
encore ce mot là mais qu'il est déjà
avec la chine et c'est vrai que la
france résiste elle résiste à cette
stratégie américaine en indo pacifique
elle prétend pouvoir agir différemment
d'autant plus qu'elle a elle aussi pas
les mêmes mais quand même des moyens
li terre dans la région et notamment des
des bateaux et des intérêts puisque la
france a des seins des territoires dans
cette région donc c'est aussi ça que joe
biden a voulu en quelque sorte punir
quand quand on antico t-il fait c'est
quand ils créent enfin c'est ce n'est
pas lui qui l'a initié mais cette année
l'alliance entre les trois pays anglo
saxons aurait pu pourquoi pas s'ouvrir à
la france qui a deux ans était justement
une stratégie dans la région et bien si
si si c'est si cette alliance n'a pas
été ouverte à la france est juste c'est
aussi parce que la france ne partage pas
la vision
chinoise de l'amérique quant aux
australiens et oui aux britanniques qui
se sont rangés derrière la vision
américaine mais c'est cette résistance
française qui agace washington on va
revenir justement sur sur la fureur de
la france dont on parlait au début de
cet entretien on se dit isabelle
lasserre que que la puissance de la
france dans cette zone indo pacifique
dont on peut voir une carte si si ryad
mais qui rend en régie peut nous l'a
montré et ce que représente la zone indo
pacifique ce qui est un vaste territoire
la france il ya des territoires est là
aussi près de deux millions de
ressortissants qui vivent sur cette zone
là on imagine que cette puissance de la
france dans ce lieu elle ne dépend pas
uniquement de l'annulation ou de la
vente de sous marins nucléaires à
l'australie on imagine est-ce que se
camoufler australo américain n'est pas à
relativiser
non je ne crois pas franchement je pense
au contraire que l'histoire va laisser
des marques et des traces pendant très
très longtemps et de facto la stratégie
indo pacifique de la france dans la
région est remise en cause parce que
la france n'a plus
des alliés aussi solide
l'australie pendant à mon avis quelques
années ne sera plus cette analyse solide
autour
duquel étaient organisées de la
stratégie indo pacifique de la france
ortin en fait elles renvoient les
internautes sur le papier isabelle
lasserre publié ce matin dans le prix du
fioul sur le site internet c'est une
véritable trahison de l'australie vis à
vis de la wii c'est une trahison je fais
ni juste parce qu'en fait la stratégie
la stratégie française en indo pacifique
elle repose sur deux jambes la première
jambe et l australie et la deuxième
jambe c'est l'inde aujourd'hui il n'y a
plus qu'une jambe donc elle et elle est
en train de boiter donc quels alliés la
france pourra se trouver pour remplacer
l'australie est ce que ce n'est par
exemple le japon c'est possible nous
parle t et japon justement comment
réagit le japon est-ce que sebastien
feval vous avez vous avez
moyen de nous dire un peu le
positionnement du japon par rapport au
camouflet
australo-américain que vient de subir la
france
il ya deux choses que le japon fait
partie des plus proches alliés des
etats-unis est donc en fait le japon
comme les autres et la région très
proche des états unis qui sont en
première ligne face à la menace chinoise
on pense aussi à taiwan se félicite de
la hocus parce que pour eux il monte le
signe que les états unis sont vraiment
là pour rester trop longtemps il faut
quand même comprendre une chose c'est
qu'il est effectivement il ya eu la
trahison au delà des aspects morale
lâche décision australienne repose sur
aussi une analyse stratégique un
changement de braquet stratégique pour
entre un sous marins conventionnels et
un sous-marin nucléaire qu'est la
différence majeure c'est que dans le cas
précis les sous marins nucléaires vont
permettre avec une plus longue autonomie
aux sous marins australiens d'aller
patrouille est très longtemps en mer de
chine du sud au large de taïwan alors
quand est un sous marins conventionnels
traditionnel ses missions aurait été
beaucoup plus compliqué parce qu'elles
ont moins de d'autonomie et donc ce que
ça veut dire c'est que l'australie entre
le moment en 2016 lors qu'elle a signé
l'accord avec la france et aujourd'hui
elle a révisé son analyse de la menace
chinoise elle estime que la machine wade
beaucoup plus forte et que donc il faut
se déployer beaucoup plus loin pour
aller chatouiller si vous voulez les
forces chinoises la marine chinoise avec
des sous marins qui ont une autonomie
plus forte et on oublie de le dire
souvent mais ce n'est que cet accord
s'est pas seulement les sous marins
nucléaires c'est aussi des armements de
longue portée notamment des tomahawk qui
font partie du package et qui vont
permettre aussi aux australiens de
menacer la chine donc c'est cette
analyse là et cette analyse là parentale
est partagé bien sûr par d'autres pays
comme le japon comme
à taïwan
mais bien sûr tous ces pays là ce il
souhaite que le plus de pays s'engage
dans la région pour revenir à votre
question sur la france un pays comme le
japon a récemment conduit des exercices
conjointe au mois de mai dernier il ya
des militaires français qui était sur
l'île de kyushu au japon et nous mener
ensemble des opérations d exercice donc
la coopération entre le japon et la
france est forte effectivement le
contexte actuel on pourrait imaginer
qu'elle soit une des possibilités pour
que la stratégie française retrouve en
partie notre gendre comme le disait
isabelle mais je suis d'accord avec elle
la stratégie française dans la région et
en est un aujourd'hui fait face à un
véritable
remise en cause et elle a besoin de
repenser sa stratégie et trouver
d'autres partenaires pour pouvoir
exister dans cette zone qui va être la
zone centrale où le 21ème siècle sera ce
jour a
rappelé évidemment parce que ce que dit
sébastien est tout à fait vrai il faut
juste quand même rappeler que la france
a des sous marins nucléaires et des
russes qu'elle propose à l'australie ce
sont des sous marins nucléaires et que
l'australie dit non non non non on veut
une propulsion au classique puisque nous
on est anti nucléaire alors l'australie
a changé de braquet et quand il ya eu
des signaux négatifs et des rumeurs en
australie qui faisait état du revirement
pro nucléaire entre guillemets du
nouveau premier ministre
les français ont approché les
australiens et en gros ils leur ont
proposé de réévaluer le contrat est de
remettre la question de la propulsion
nucléaire sur le tapis c'est très
important parce que on est des gens
sympa si d'habitude c'est david hussein
se fait par ouï de vendre des
sous-marins nucléaires une technologie
nucléaire à un pays qui n'est pas doté
de l'armé nucléaire pour des raisons de
non prolifération absolument nucléaire
les australiens ont fait la sourde
oreille
ils ont menti ils ont dit non non non
non finalement la propulsion classique
nous va tout à fait bien donc la france
avait des sous marins dont on était en
capacité de leur fournir voilà alors
qu'ils n'ont pas les mêmes que les
américains mais juste sur la technologie
nucléaire les australiens pouvez la voir
isabelle lasserre est ce que la chine
ces méprises sur un déclin possible de
la première puissance américaine
certains ont affirmé effectivement que
leur très chaotique un d'afghanistan
était un signe d'affaiblissement c'est
la chine qui sait qui c'est mais la
chine la chine et la chine étant à mon
avis un des pays qui qui sait à quel
point la puissance américaine est
toujours debout et là puisqu'elle se
justement elle se redéploie face à la
chine dans cette région ce qui sont
bercés d'illusions ce sont les autres
les sons les occidentaux et surtout les
les européens qui ont vu dans leur
travail distant à qui venait après le
retrait de deux scieries le désintérêt
manifesté par obama d'abord puis par
trump et enfin par byden vis-à-vis de
l'europe qui ont vu donc le début du
déclin de la puissance américaine voilà
pas du tout les etats-unis sont toujours
la première puissance du monde ils sont
toujours là la puissance américaine
militairement et économiquement se porte
à merveille simplement on la regarde
avec des lunettes européenne et tout se
passe à l'est sébastien fallait-il à
deux ça veut dire que la chine n'a pas
été surprise de de ce contrat cet accord
au cuss signé avec les partenaires anglo
saxons des américains
la chine depuis quelques années surtout
depuis le moment trump a compris que les
états unis avaient révisé leur vision de
la chine il ya eu un tournant qui s'est
passé depuis quelques années au moment
du
donald trump qui a dit ouvertement des
choses qui montait à washington dc
depuis longtemps et joe biden qu'est ce
qu'il fait lui il prolonge cette
approche trompe ciel mais avec la
méthode est en simple il est en train de
recomposer tisser un nouveau réseau
d'alliances donc la chine voit ça se
dérouler la chine et moderne totalement
très inquiète et
elle avance à la poussa encore plus
renforcé son effort militaire qui est
spectaculaire surtout sur le plan
maritime il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
grâce aux efforts fantastiques des
chantiers navals chinois la marine de
l'armée populaire de libération donc
l'armée chinoise est plus importante que
l'us navy
donc c'est spectaculaire alors bien sûr
sur le plan technique il ya toujours un
fossé important et c'est là où les
sous-marins joue un rôle très important
c'est que les sous-marins la guerre
sous-marine c'est l'un des points
faibles de la marine chinoise encore et
les états unis et l'australie ici
clairement sans comprendre aux chinois
vous êtes en train de développer des
missiles vous avez une capacité de force
de plus en plus forte pour au large des
côtes chinoises donc il va falloir que
nous passions sous les eaux pour pouvoir
continuer à tenir quelques chinois avec
un enjeu majeur pour les prochaines
années c'est la stratégie chinoise c'est
d'établir ce qu'on appelle un déni
d'accès dans toute la zone des premiers
maillons deal ce qu'on appelle ce qui va
à peu près de la corée taïwan
philippines mer de chine du sud c'est ça
le bras de fer fondamentale des
prochaines décennies c'est ils veulent
empêcher les américains de rentrer là
dedans et donc les aima 90 ray-ban on va
passer avec des sous marins et avec des
ailiers la soeur isabelle lasserre les
rapports entretenus par washington et
pékin étaient pour le moins tendues
avant cette affaire quelles vont être
les rapports désormais entre les deux
pays c'est clairement un rapport de
compétiteur il ya cette fois passer une
étape une étape supplémentaire et une
étape supérieure kampaï dundee et qui
assure halloween et qui ne veut pas de
guerre froide avec la chine on ne peut
pas considérer déjà qu'il ya la guerre
froide elle existe déjà alors c'est tout
le débat est ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut
utiliser le même terme parce que les
différences où ils ont sont énormes et
notamment l'interdépendance énorme au
niveau économique entre entre ces deux
puissances empire qui n'était pas du
tout là à l'époque de l'union soviétique
entre avec les états unis mais sinon la
guerre froide
elle existe bel et bien aujourd'hui
c'est pas contradiction lutte entre
hayden deux modèles de façon oui beau
joe biden il cherche quoi en affirmant
que je ne veux pas de guerre froide en
fait sachant qu'elle est la fille
véritablement
je pense que joe biden ne veut pas de
guerre chaude
la stratégie américaine aujourd'hui
consiste à reprendre l'ascendant et
contenir la montée de la chine tout en
évitant que ça se termine mal dans la
région mais c'est un peu un peu
compliqué et beaucoup de personnes qui
nous regardent ou qui lisent la presse
endiguer la chine ou contrer l'hégémonie
chinoise sans entrer en conflit ouvert
avec avec la chine
ça dépend oui c'est à dire que ça va
passer
le danger n'est pas la confrontation
directe rares blog comme ça mais il ya
effectivement des points ultra sensible
qui dans les années qui viennent pour
ont dégénéré je pense notamment
effectivement à la question de à la
question de taiwan qui est quand même le
l'espèce de grenade pas encore
dégoupillée dans la région mais
pourrait s'enflammer assez rapidement
sébastien falletti a un vrai conflit un
futur conflit est il à craindre dans la
zone indo pacifique
alors comme l'a dit isabelle clairement
les deux grandes puissances
personne ne veut un conflit parce que ça
un conflit catastrophique pour les deux
présentent pour le monde entier avec des
possibles réactions en chaîne nucléaire
donc clairement que ce soit le président
shipping président joe biden ils ne
veulent surtout pas qu'on en arrive là
mais comme on le voit souvent dans
l'histoire les conflits en général
démarre sur des erreurs de calcul sur
des incompréhensions et aujourd'hui on
est entré dans une zone dans l'anneau
pacifique où les deux géants ne se font
plus du tout confiance il y a un défi
d'un manque de confiance et on se méfie
de l'autre est il donc les canaux de
communication entre les militaires sont
insuffisants donc toute la question
c'est si jamais il y à un accrochage en
mer comme cela est arrivé par le passé
ou par des avions
comme c'est arrivé par le passé comment
on gère ce genre de situation dans un
contexte où il y à une méfiance tél donc
il n'ya pas de volonté de conflits
maintenant par contre il y à une
confrontation de fondamental entre deux
systèmes de valeurs entre des intérêts
économiques et technologiques et cette
confrontation est là pour longtemps pour
les décennies et cette confrontation
les européens ne vont pas y échapper
c'est à dire que le discours en europe
de dire ah on renvoie dos à dos les
américains et les chinois c'est pas
notre affaire ça c'est un discours
illusoire parce que c'est en jeu ce sont
les enjeux de comment votre appareil
fonctionne ce sont les enjeux de comment
votre commerce vous pouvez ait pu
échanger vos les enjeux politiques de
respect de certains droits humains à
l'échelle de la planète si tous ces
enjeux-là qui sont derrière ce conflit
donc c'est un conflit fondamental et
c'est pour ça qu'il va durer et le
problème c'est que comme ça peut durer
ya les risques
d'inflammation seront pl dans les années
signe à venir isabelle lasserre comme le
dit sébastien falletti est-ce que
l'avenir de l'union européenne et est
lié à celui de la région indo pacifique
d'un point de vue géologique et
géopolitique je réponds juste jeu je
voulais juste à josé quelque chose en
fait c'est là la différence avec la
guerre froide et oui vous souvenez
charlotte pendant la guerre froide
venons vous n'étiez pas d'aimer mes dd
téléphone rouge en fait absolument oui
il n'y a pas ces téléphones rouges il
n'y a pas il ya plus est entre la maison
blanche et la paix car oui absolument et
c'est et c'est en ça que c'est très très
très très dangereux pour pour rebondir
sur les différences de les difficultés
de falla non fluidité
peut-être l'indication istc téléphone
rentrée à l'époque de vous en cas de
d'énormes catastrophe il nie direct qui
relie les deux présidents et on peut
apaiser les choses bougent tout ça
évidemment théorique parce que si jamais
le président le dit les croche mais
alors ces bénévoles c'est lui c'était
les fautes et les formes d'autres moyens
aujourd'hui où absolument aucun moyen
genre et abou jahjah pas cette fluidité
communication qui pouvaient exister à
l'époque face à cette espèce de 2,2
cadenas de sécurité il n'est pas le même
il est beaucoup moins beaucoup moins
fort beaucoup moins puissant pour en
revenir à l'europe écoutez oui non je
l'europe et l'europe est complètement
absente en indo pacifique c'est une
question de géographie quand on voit une
carte on comprend une carte du monde on
comprend pourquoi il n'y a que là les
deux pays me ferai des deux pays qui
sont présents en indo pacifique assez
fortement c'est la france et la
grande-bretagne qui n'est plus dans
l'union européenne
parce qu'elles ont des intérêts
particuliers puis d une puissance
militaire et aussi de projection
marine conséquente c'est pas s'est passé
pas le cas de nos autres alliés
européens la france quand elle a lancé
sa
stratégie pour l'inde au pacifique
emmanuel macron l'a fait d'ailleurs
depuis une base militaire australienne
c'est vous dire sur cette charlotte à
quel point on considérait ce partenariat
stratégique fort fort et ce livre est là
depuis essayé d'entraîner des pays
européens mais le problème c'est que la
france est relativement isolé à les
isoler en indo pacifique comme elle est
isolée dans le sahel comme elle est
isolée à chaque fois qu'on parle de deux
drops puissance de nécessité de de
s'affirmer par enfin ça tous les périls
qui monte en fait il n'ya qu'un seul
pays aujourd'hui depuis le départ de la
grande bretagne en europe qui a une
vision globale du monde c la france y
ait une seule il ya un seul pays qui
poussent aussi fort ce désir et cette
nécessité d'avoir une europe puissance
c'est la france est aujourd'hui elle est
bien isolé et bien isolée pourtant se
pose maintenant la question d'une
stratégie européenne forte justement
pour intervenir une troisième voie qui
sont telles que sauf quand la question
de la stratégie européenne farid elle se
pose depuis toujours elle s'est posée
vis-à-vis de la russie elle s'est posée
vis-à-vis du terrorisme au sahel
aujourd'hui elle se pose vers la chine
est moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que on
a une europe qui est composé
essentiellement de deux pays bisounours
et que leur soutien la france est tardif
est très mou et que
ce continent malgré toutes les promesses
de de la commission européenne qui avait
pro qui avec avait assuré qu'elle serait
une commission
géopolitique l'europe ne brille pas
alors qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour que
l'europe enfin se réveille parce que là
dessus la france a raison oui parce que
là on regarde les faits on a
l'impression qu' il n'y a pas eu
beaucoup de soutien beaucoup de
réactions européennes autour de la
france pour soutenir la cense sondés ce
sont des larmes de crocodile c'est à
dire qu'au bout de cinq jours un petit
peu il a dû y avoir un coup de téléphone
du président français
la présidente de la commission a enfin
enfin eu des mots assez fort en disant
qu'il trouvait ça scandaleux en soutien
à la france et puis quelques heures
après on la voyait commenté une réunion
avec le premier ministre australien
scott morrison en disant que en gros il
fallait écouter toutes les versions mais
c'est pareil voilà et quant aux quant au
cantou chancelier quant au jeune
chancelier autrichien courte ce qui
aurait normalement kinki docking dans
cette fatigue qui a soutenu qui en
théorie aurait dû soutenir les propos de
de la commission parce que c'est un peu
l'unanimité lui c'est encore pire il a
trouvé son rendez vous avec scott
morrison formidable et en gros il prend
son parti donc ce sont des larmes de
crocodile elles ont coulé très tard et
elles sont très vite elles ont très vite
séchées et donc on al impression qu
effectivement c'est un problème national
il perçu comme un problème national
plutôt qu'un problème européen c'est ça
le problème tous les pays européens
disent ok c'est la france a perdu un
contrat pas du tout ça n'a rien à voir
avec le contrat le contrat
comme le disait tout à l'heure sébastien
la france même si entre alliés on peut
il ya des engagements qui en général se
sont tenues on peut aussi comprendre que
pour l'australie le l'environnement
stratégique et est à ce point changé que
l'australie soit plus en sécurité sous
parapluie militaire américain que sous
le parapluie militaire français ça c'est
normal il ya deux choses il ya ça après
il ya la manière dont ça s'est passé qui
est une trahison des mensonges et
dissimulations
digne de deux pays qui sont des
adversaires de la france digne de l'iran
digne de la turquie digne de la russie
fin on est habitué à ce que vladimir
poutine manteau président français quand
il prétend que alexeï navalni ces autos
empoisonné l'opposant on a l'habitude
que les iraniens membres sur le
programme nucléaire
mais parler mais bâloise australien va
les australiens et la manière dont ça a
été fait je vous de nouveau je vous
renvoie sur le papier isabelle lasserre
paru dans le print aujourd'hui et sur
lefigaro.fr sur cette trahison
australienne est sur les manoeuvres de
ce premier ministre qui a donc sollicité
dans un premier temps boris johnson
avant de convaincre la maison blanche
juste sur la position de la france dans
la zone indo pacifique et la possibilité
qui aurait pu se présenter ou qui peut
être pourrait se présenter plus tard
d'intégrer ce pacte hocus on rappelle
que la france à 7000 soldats et près de
2 millions de ressortissants basée dans
la zone indo pacifique est-ce qu'elle
n'était pas un partenaire ac ou
suffisamment crédible pour les
américains indépendamment de sa
perception et sa vision de ses rapports
avec la chine bien sûr qu'elle l'est et
bailon
agi de manière
sans doute enfin c'est pas forcément
intelligence le pari de baden parce que
maintenant il sait ni quand même son
ancien meilleur allié en europe à dos et
en ouvrant cette alliance à la france il
donne aurait entraîné l'europe donc bien
évidemment c'était la chose à faire
alors pourquoi n'at-il pas fait il n'y a
pas fait c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure parce que notamment parce que la
france d'abord il ya eu d'alliance quand
même particulier entre les îles anglo
saxons qui sont liés par les failles
weiser leurs services de renseignement
les traditions culturelles c'est quand
même un petit un club
qui ne partagent pas ses secrets
avec les autres y compris avec les
alliés ainsi donc là ça aurait posé un
un problème mais c'est aussi parce que
la france n'a pas la vision des pays
occidentaux vis-à-vis des vis-à-vis de
la chine et qu'elle ne veut pas rentrer
en confrontation avec la chine et
qu'elle propose une voie différente de
la voix américaine et le grande
legrand
différents en fait de entre les
etats-unis et la france depuis plusieurs
années c'est justement cette pause est
avec l'europe en général c'est cette
position
européenne vis-à-vis de la chine
l'europe ne veut pas ne veut pas se
ranger à part donc bien entendu boris
johnson qui ne fait plus parler de
l'union européenne l'europe ne veut pas
se ranger dans la confrontation ne veut
pas soutenir
lalalala comprendre la manière
confrontation elle
d abord les américains vis-à-vis de ses
vis-à-vis de la chine peut-être que
c'est ce point-là de friction dont on a
du mal à comprendre l'importance
du poids qu'elle peut avoir justement
dans des décisions comme celles qui ont
été prises et de ce pacte qui a été acté
avec l'australie et le royaume uni
sébastien falletti revenons sur la vente
des sous-marins puisque
beaucoup de commentaires faisait part de
de la crainte et le fait qu'ils pointent
du doigt la question de la prolifération
nucléaire dont vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure la problématique ont repris 6
que les américains ont
acté et donné leur accord pour un
transfert de technologie de sous marins
à propulsion atomique à canberra et aux
australiens c'est une chose qui n'a pas
de précédent à ma connaissance peut-être
une fois avec le royaume uni mais qui
est tout à fait exceptionnelle et
certains mettent en avant le fait qu'il
ya un risque de prolifération nucléaire
à ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer un
peu sur ce sujet là
alors effectivement c'est
cette décision cet accord qui est pour
le moins un accord politique sur un bout
de papier donc attendu qui doit encore
être validée pendant de longues
négociations
mais cet accord c'est vrai que c'est la
première fois que les états unis depuis
la guerre froide face à l'union
soviétique acceptent de partager cette
technologie sensible à l'époque c'était
avec le royaume uni donc si c'est
important ce symbole parce que ça c'est
une façon de dire aux australiens mais
aussi à tous les pays de la région que
les états unis sont sérieuses dans la
région sont prêts tél il estime que la
région est tellement stratégique ils
sont prêts à faire cette concession à un
allié clef maintenant il faut voir que
évidemment les émails 40 ans parce la
demande des contreparties aux
australiens en 42 présences à la chine
donc sa ligne australiens et les
américains là dessus alors sur la
question de la procédure sonne clair
comme isabelle l'a bien dit la france a
cette capacité est d'ailleurs à la base
les sous-marins français barracuda sont
des sous marins nucléaires et ce sont
les australiens l'époque avait demandé à
ce qu'ils soient propulsés de façon
conventionnelle
et amples sur la question de la
prolifération qui a été mis en avant
évidemment par la chine mais aussi par
la corée du nord notamment qu' à point
nommé a tout de suite vu là une
opportunité de dire regardez vous nous
accusez de développer un programme
nucléaire mais regardez ce que les états
unis font donc le régime de kim jong
hoon a tout de suite saisi l'opportunité
donc c'est un débat que la chine et ses
alliés vont porter à l'oeil à à l'onu
pour essayer justement de de montrer que
locus est un danger pour la paix
mondiale
la question clé c'est que ce qui est
d'autant plus ironique c'est que les
sous-marins nucléaires américains sont
propulsés avec de l'uranium fortement
enrichi qui est effectivement impose un
risque parce que cette dame ne pouvait
le transformer en bombe atomique mais
les sous-marins français eux sont
propulsés par hegel de l'uranium
faiblement enrichi donc qu'ils posent
moins de risques pour la propulsion pour
la prolifération donc une des questions
pour finir sur ce qu'on vous disiez
juste avant c'est la grande question
c'est pourquoi la france n'a pas été
inclus dans cet accord au cou ce et les
prochaines semaines prochains mois vont
dire est ce que il ya encore une
possibilité si les états unis le
souhaitait s'il était sérieux il
pourrait peut-être ouvrir une discussion
pour voir est-ce qu'il ya moyen pour la
france d'une manière ou d'une autre de
participer à cet accord parce que s'il
le faisait il ferait coup double parce
qu'il entraînerait à la fois les
européens face à la chine et illizi
bâtir est un front commun face à pékin
beaucoup plus conséquent donc ça c'est
une porte de sortie par le haut
aujourd'hui les tensions sont très
fortes entre washington et l'or et paris
ça semble difficile à imaginer mais qui
sait c'est ça va être un élément à
suivre dans les prochaines semaines et
prochains mois derrière les portes
closes
quelques remarques et commentaires de
nos internautes que nous suivent en ce
moment sur le chat du figaro au figaro
l'arrivée sur youtube nous avons pour
isabelle lasserre une question de
charles m'a c'est pas une question c'est
une réflexion charles martel merci
charles pour votre intervention ssi
trump avait gagné je ne crois pas qu'il
aurait agi comme byden et pourtant on
dit que john réagi comme trump bah en
fait
donald trump avait en fait un discours
anti européen joe biden à un discours
pro européen et sur le fond il mène
exactement la même politique vis-à-vis
de la chine et la même politique
vis-à-vis de l'europe c'est dire qu'en
fait joe biden est en train de mettre en
oeuvre les promesses faites d'abord par
barack obama puis par donald trump qui
n'avaient pas pu aller au bout vous
souvenez c'est barack obama c'est le
lancement du pivot vers l'asie trump
c'est l'affirmation ok je me retire de
tous les de tous les conflits il n'avait
pas réussi à le faire en afghanistan il
avait même été contraint d'augmenter
le contingent américain en afghanistan
provisoirement pour afin de mieux
pouvoir s'en sont retirés après ba joe
biden il applique les politiques de
barack obama et de donald trump il se
retire d'afghanistan et
il se concentre à 80%
syndicat d'eau pacifique face à la face
à la chine un commentaire de volvo est
bien la france est désormais coincé
entre l'atrazine la trahison caucus et
l'europe qui la paralyse et qui ne
soutient pas suffisamment c'est un
constat voilà que fait the vault cet
internaute peut être une réflexion de
mac 75 pour vous sébastien falletti va
de 75 10 l'australie nous en veut pour
les essais nucléaires dans le pacifique
devons-nous lui faire confiance
il ya effectivement une longue histoire
tandis entre los tres la france qui
remonte bien plus loin puisqu'elle
remonte ne l'oublions pas à l'époque
napoléonienne
l'australie colonie britannique à
l'époque avait été un moment
avec un moment une des cibles possibles
de des flottes françaises il y a un
vieux un vieux fond de rivalité entre la
france et l'australie qui est très
ancien et qui c'est vrai a été relancé à
l'époque des essais nucléaires
notamment à l'époque de jacques chirac
mais le l'accord sur les sous marins
marc est justement un tournant assez
spectaculaire dans les relations entre
canberra et paris et comme les français
me disait c'était un mariage pour 50 ans
et c'était effectivement un
investissement à long terme et il faut
se souvient aussi qu'à l'époque
l'australie se sentait assez seul parce
que à l'époque la chine commence à
monter en puissance et elle avait face à
elle un barack obama qui reste est assez
timide puis elle a eu un donald trump
qui était extrêmement isolationnistes et
donc l'australie étaient bien contents
de trouver une puissance européenne qui
avaient des capacités dans la région et
qui aligne capacités pour fabriquer ccc
sous marins pour pouvoir les pôles et ce
qui se passe simplement aujourd'hui
c'est qu'effectivement l'échelle de la
menace chinoise
a changé et surtout avec l'australie car
les cinq gars année entre pékin et
l'australie sont devenus
une véritable escalade le serait il
devenu la tête de turc de pékin
éthique de deux d'agressivité
commerciale l'arrestation de ses deux
ressortissants australiens en chine
c'était véritablement un bras de fer qui
fait peur
aux australiens et donc il ya eu un
changement d'échelle de la menace est
dans ce contexte évidemment la france se
retrouve évincé et on assiste à la mise
en place d'une forme de deux blocs en
asie et effectivement la fameuse
troisième voie donc par les labels se
rétrécit de plus en plus donc le grand
défi pour la france et comment faire
pour exister encore cette zone alors que
l'espace stratégie qui est en train de
se réduire alors l'internaute jlr sur le
chat ou youtube a peut être une solution
puisqu'il nous dit la france va présider
l'union européenne du 1er janvier au 30
juin 2022 et pourra influencer dans le
sens d'une europe plus forte au niveau
militaire que penser de cette réflexion
de jlr si seulement 6 allemand ça fait
ça fait combien d'années et deux
décennies que la france essaie
d'influencer ses partenaires pour les
amener à soutenir une europe plus forte
alors ses aventures se félicite de
petites de petits progrès le fait est
que pour l'instant l'europe puissance
elle n'est dans le dans la vo la fin
elle n'existe que dans l'esprit que dans
l'esprit de la france un certain nombre
d'internautes évidemment font référence
à l'otan et la légitimité aujourd'hui
d'être encore dans l'otan pour la france
qu'est-ce qu'on peut répondre à ces
internautes qui s'interrogent en disant
par exemple d'amérique rodado que
l'europe puissante est soumise à l'otan
ne leur en veux pas du tout soumises
d'ailleurs la meilleure preuve c'est que
c'est elle en est l'un des principaux
fauteurs de troubles en tout cas depuis
la petite phrase de d'emmanuel macron
sur la mort cérébrale qui pointait à
juste titre d'ailleurs les faiblesses de
l'otan ces incohérences et surtout
les comportements
extrêmement
antipathique des alliés c'est une petite
musique le partir de l'otan qu'on entend
régulièrement
ce sera mon avis une erreur
une véritable erreur la france serait
seul il faut quand même rappeler qu'on
n'est pas du tout allez on n'est pas du
tout on n'est pas du tout à la même
époque celle de du général de gaulle
quand il se retourne quand il se retire
du du commandement intégré de l'otan à
l'époque la france avait 5 % de
croissance et elle consacrait 5% son
budget à la défense
j'ai pas besoin de vous
faire la comparaison avec les chiffres
d'aujourd'hui donc que l'otan doivent
être réformées et que des questions se
posent
sans doute est ce ce travail de
modernisation et de reconcentration
stratégique doit être doit être fait
quitter l'otan la france très seul or
qui d'autre que l'otan aujourd'hui au
niveau militaire défendue en tout cas
est en capacité de défendre les intérêts
européens en cas de gros pépin et ben
c'est pas l'heure de la différence elle
n'existe pas
on va terminer cette émission sur sur
ces paroles d'isabelle lasserre merci
encore de nous avoir suivis en direct
sur figaro live et sur le chat youtube
et la chaîne figaro live sur youtube
merci sébastien falletti pour vos
éclairages sur la chine et vos
explications merci d'avoir répondu aux
internautes en direct ce matin merci
isabelle lasserre pour votre expertise à
très vite sur figaro live et n'oubliez
pas d'aller jeter un oeil et plus que ça
même de lire le passionnant la
passionnante enquête d'isabelle lasserre
sur la trahison australienne a publié
aujourd'hui
hu